[Music]
you're gonna be a dwarf in the next
Hobbit movie were you excited about
where you are you a fan of the The
Hobbit Tolkien hobbits no no late late
the movies very much but I never read
the books what did you sit in Peter
Jackson know that first thing he asked
me he said have you read The Hobbit I
said no and I don't like people who have
he said that the Peter Jackson the guy
who's built his whole life around Wow
thank credit Buster laughing yeah was it
was it fun I mean it must be a ton of
makeup and oh three hours a day right
and to look like a dwarf the build
you've weighed right so you come down
and start to and then they shoot you a
certain way yeah and the backgrounds
will change respective and you will this
is very very hot so you will this
undershirt that there's little page scan
through it that the nd you come off
sweating and they plug you in and they
squirt freezing water through it
that is the strangest thing I've ever
heard they actually have like a cooling
system healed in yeah and they and they
they shoot you up with cold water yes
when you get up you try not to do it too
often because you get sick you make it
hard cold hot cold isn't good for you
right now I'm gonna bring up something
that's that's serious
and this happens since I talked to you
last but you were diagnosed with
Parkinson's is that correct yeah matter
of fact that was the last time I did
this sure you put me up in a hotel in
Los Angeles Sunday I was coming in going
in there till after the show and there
was a lot of people in the lobby they
had been Australian dance team there was
a guy in charge of them and he was a
doctor and he came over to me one day
they said Billy am i fine and I was good
he said listen I've been watching you're
walking in and out here they said I
think you've been early onset
Parkinson's disease go and see your
doctor he just so this is someone who
you're here to do the show you're
staying at a hotel you do our show
you're there and you bump into a doctor
who said I have a hunch yeah and you
went it was right right what do you are
you what are you on you're obviously on
your medications no they took me off the
medication the vegam that side effects
for
longer than the effects because it's
very early days you know right and it's
that we have medicine and I said well
what are the same effects and they said
and an over-reading interest in sex and
gambling so if you see someone in Las
Vegas with an erection he's probably at
parking
[Applause]